on est ici chez différents et on va
découvrir michel cette fameuse van dijk
qui comporte des disques vinyles des 45
tours 6 à des carences
c'est une génération qu'on ne trouve
plus mais voilà on l'a on lille 3 c'est
donc dans un classeur une valisette d'un
côté invités à la fois de rang chez nous
aussi devons agir d'accord et en a qu'on
est d'environ michel dans ce livre il ya
une quinzaine de disques qui seront du
matin une quinzaine de pochettes dans
les faits l'on peut ranger de 2 à 4 10
on peut sortir juste 1 ni que vous à
sortir
info a alors là je tombe sur quelque
chose de particulier voilà c'est un
disque alors la pochette et manière
justement a été voit shechtman mots
alors que nous allons trouver une autre
pochette comme celle-ci ernesto les arts
d où là on a une photo et là on est dans
les années 50 60
c'est un magnifique patrimoine saint
michel qu'on arrive à la soie par chance
je ne suis pas assez jour ou avoir été
l'acquéreur de ces dix là mais en tout
cas j'ai eu la chance de rencontrer le
détenteur